le maire sortant est réélu avec moins de
la moitié des voix et il réalise
également son plus mauvais résultat
depuis depuis 2001 nous ce qui nous
inquiète aujourd'hui nous prenons acte
bien sûr dans un esprit républicain deux
de ses résultats ce qui nous inquiète
c'est deux choses la première c'est que
nous pensons que ce quatrième mandat et
le mandat de trop et nous sommes
inquiets à cet égard d'autant plus qu'on
ne voit pas très bien à quoi il va
ressembler et la deuxième chose c'est
que nous sommes inquiets sur le fond par
la dégradation de la situation des
dijonnais en termes de qualité de vie et
en termes de sécurité
en particulier nous avons nous l'avons
exposé dans cette dans cette campagne
donc nous n'avons pas été suffisamment
entendu mais nous sommes inquiets et
l'engagement que nous prenons
aujourd'hui bien sûr ces deux c'est
d'être mobilisés pour défendre les
intérêts des dijonnaises et des
dijonnais durant tout son mandat est de
leur donner rendez vous dans six ans